no hay tiempo que perder el tramo final
de la campaña electoral acelera en
francia con la mira puesta en el 24 de
abril día en el que el presidente de
manuel mckeown y la lidereza de extrema
derecha a marie le pen se juegan su
futuro político por delante menos de dos
semanas para sumar la mayoría de los
apoyos que al contrario que en 2017
donde macrón terminó sacando más de 30
puntos al epen parece estar más reñido
el presidente visitó el lunes regiones
del norte de francia feudos que ha
logrado conquistar lepén en los últimos
tiempos allí defendió una de sus
propuestas electorales más
controvertidas para el electorado
lepenista el retraso de la edad de
jubilación de los 62 a los 65 años en el
programa de moda anne payne que su
vecino defiende dice que no cambiamos
nada en las pensiones ya hace cinco años
decía que la retrasaríamos a los 60 años
yo creo que con los fondos que tenemos
nuestro sistema es de reasignación que
es son los trabajadores activos los que
financian la jubilación de los
pensionistas por su parte la
ultraconservadora también en el norte
aprovecho para encontrarse con sus
seguidores en una hacienda ganadera
donde quiso hacer hincapié en los
agravios que según ella la política
económica del centrista dejó en los
últimos cinco años
más allá del aumento del precio del gas
del combustible de la electricidad y de
los carburantes a la que se enfrentan
hoy los franceses hay otra nube oscura
que se cierne sobre la cabeza de los
franceses y que va a hacer la inflación
de los precios de los alimentos ya se ha
basado esta inflación desde que manuel
macrón asumió el cargo las frutas y las
verduras han jugado a un 25 por ciento
en el sprint final al elíseo se estrecha
la diferencia entre las proyecciones
ganadoras de los candidatos según los
sondeos electorales según estimaciones
de ipsos o prestaría para france 24 el
presidente obtendría un 54% de apoyo
frente al 46% del epen